okay a lot of reaction to my appearance
still now a month ago in the Joe Rogan
experience out in Los Angeles and I got
a few different versions of this next
question which generally speaking is
here's one example of how the question
was asked David now you that you've
appeared on the Joe Rogan program can we
reasonably reasonably believe that you
are an official member of the
intellectual dark web where
theoretically where theoretically do you
now fit on the alt-right network map if
just for some giggles yeah I don't think
I'm anywhere on the I'm I'm the only all
right map I'm on is the map of targets
right that's the only one I don't know
it listen I I don't know who's in or out
of the intellectual dark web I don't
profess to be in or out I just don't
have really any clue what the boundaries
are of the intellectual dark web what is
very interesting though is that since
the Rogen appearance a lot of my content
that is posted on mostly left-wing
subreddits has also been appearing on
the intellectual intellectual dark web
subreddit on the Sam Harris subreddit
etc and it is very interesting that on
the one hand you have the what's called
the bread tuber coalition bread tube
there's a prominent subreddit which is
definitively lefty content it's
exclusively lefty content and then on
the other hand you have the intellectual
dark web which is Pro free speech Center
left to right wing content there's a
variety of views represented within the
intellectual dark web online enclaves
and some of my same pieces of content
are being posted to the bread Tube
affiliated sub reddits and to the IDW
affiliated subreddit which is
interesting and maybe I mean listen
sometimes I get criticized for being
boring because I see both sides of a lot
of issues when there aren't two
reasonable sides I don't see both sides
like the abortion debate I don't find
any value in the abortion is murder and
it should be a legal thing like that I
just don't even know how to integrate
that into my perspective on what
abortion law should be and that'll
actually be the topic of the next
audience question but on a lot of these
issues nuance is required identity
politics toxic identity politic
where one's identity is used as a cudgel
or as a knife or as a mallet to beat
people over the head with is bad it's
not the biggest issue but it's bad and I
call it out I also recognize that to
ignore the reality that people's
identity as representative of who they
are may bring them unique perspectives
on political issues that should be
listened to
it's just like the most my nude amount
of nuance and apparently in some circles
that qualifies that both as a bread tube
perspective and as an IDW perspective I
don't know but certainly I've received
no official or unofficial invitation to
the intellectual dark web although there
there were actually some tweets floating
around last week about maybe me
appearing on Bret Weinstein's
Weinstein's new podcast of wind I don't
never remember why weinstein i believe
his new podcast to talk about what's
going on with youtube d monetization and
i would lie mean i'll appear anywhere to
talk about that issue i think it's an
important issue that should be discussed
one of today's sponsors is impeach the
card slap game you can't slap donald
trump in real life but you can slap them
in this really funny and intelligent to
player card game and you can get it for
10% off at david pakman.com slash
impeach impeach the card game is perfect
for having friends over hanging out with
family members who have a sense of humor
about trump we've been playing it at my
place I really don't think you'd be able
to find a game that does a better job of
satirizing today's political climate in
such an intelligent way I've had a ton
of fun with it I think you will too you
can tell a ton of time and careful
thought went into the game design and
the cartoon artwork and the humor it
never gets old because you're always
discovering new jokes and political
commentary in the game we were talking
to the creators of the game and they
said one of the goals was that players
might even learn something new as they
play I think it would make a perfect
gift for anyone really of any political
orientation because of how clever it is
and when you go to david pakman.com
slash in peach you'll get 10% off the
game but you can also get 10% off any of
the hilarious clothing and accessories
in the online store including t-shirts
coffee mugs tote bags all featuring
funny original political cartoons
about the president get a super fun and
witty gift for yourself or someone you
know whether it's impeach the card slap
game or any of the other awesome stuff
in the gift shop and get ten percent off
of all of it when you go to david
pakman.com slash impeach